[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we turn
to a married couple in virginia hannah
and blair keely who are getting some
media attention because of their claim
that they have never once in 30 years of
marriage argued or raised their voices
with one another never once never done
it now they for some reason released a
joint statement to fox news digital
where they made this claim and also
imparted seven tips so that you also can
have a perfect relationship
now i do kind of like the idea of
releasing joint statements to the press
with random facts about your marriage
like my wife and i um could release a
joint statement and hold a press
conference about the fact that we have
never once through our entire marriage
owned a microwave
that's true so maybe we released a joint
statement
who who wants to know or cares is the
other question
anyway right up front and assessing the
legitimacy of this claim and also the
credibility of the people making it
there there are a few strikes for them
and against them now here's something in
their favor they've been married for 30
years and they have uh seven grown
children
now if you want to claim to be a
relationship expert
you're not even in the running unless
you're married obviously and have
remained married to the same person
but to get to expert status you have to
at least have i think three decades
under your belt so they're just over the
line there and you have to have raised
children yeah i i sorry i don't want to
hear any relationship advice from
childless people
because it's a different ball game once
you have kids on the scene these people
have seven as far as i know all of their
kids are currently uh not in prison none
of them are serial killers as far as i
know so uh the keeley's did something
right all that is to their credit
there are some red flags though in the
article hannah is described as a master
life coach and her husband is in
marketing so you see a combination here
life coach marketing sending this out
claiming they've never had any arguments
you know maybe there's something there
um actually on her linkedin bio hannah
describes herself as america's number
one mom coach and founder of mom mastery
university it's also she's a reality tv
host
now i'm not sure who america's number
two and number three mom coaches are or
how these things are ranked
or if number two and number three know
that they're number two and number three
and would agree with that i have no idea
um now no doubt
there are some wise people in this world
who give great advice
okay
you're looking at one of them but when a
person goes into the business of being a
wise person who gives great advice and
aggressively markets themselves as such
you begin to become a little bit
skeptical
because
the first thing any wise person knows is
that you should not go around claiming
that you are wise socrates could have
told you that the whole concept of life
coaching i think is a bit absurd for
this reason and also because there's no
requirements right in order to be a life
coach
anyone can wake up one day you could
have it overweight out of shape
unemployed alcoholic could wake up one
day and say you know what i'm a life
coach now and i'm an expert in life
and they can just start coaching you on
how to live so i find that dubious
but we could put aside
most of that and look at what the kiwis
are actually saying about marriage
most of the tips they give are pretty
good um pretty obvious and kind of
cliche but they're valid nonetheless
tips like share your feelings and
expectations and challenge each other to
grow
now these
tips are not actually necessary i mean
you don't need to tell a woman to share
her feelings there's no reason to write
that down no woman no no wife is gonna
read that and say you know what i should
share my i never thought to share my
feelings with my husband um that's you
know wife wives generally don't do
anything but share their feelings
um so but that's that's all fair enough
some tips are bad
they offer the classic never go to bed
angry thing in the explanation we're
told hannah and blair keeley insist it's
important for couples not to go to bed
angry that's because nighttime is when
humans often encode their cognitive
experiences from earlier in the day
in a couple's own words anger towards
your spouse can easily turn into a
belief if you don't manage the thought
prior to bedtime how do we do this they
continue to always affirm the love you
have for that person even if there's no
resolution the ultimate conflict
resolution is making the decision the
conscious decision to love
and the problem here is that anger is an
emotion
you can't simply turn off and on like a
light switch all the time so if you're
buying into this ridiculous idea that
you should never allow yourself to fall
asleep while you're angry at your spouse
all that means is that is that you're
going to force yourself to stay awake
and your spouse to stay awake while you
continue to hash out your issue
until you aren't angry anymore but it's
pretty rare that people get less angry
and arguments get less tense the later
it gets
sleep deprivation tends to fuel anger
and irritation not cure it
okay so in fact many times the best
thing you could possibly do when you're
angry is go to bed that's actually the
best thing
um
like 99 of the of the arguments that
you've ever had at night you would have
been better off just going to bed
and you wake up the next morning
now with some rest and a little bit of
time and a lot of times you see that
what you were angry about was kind of
unimportant and silly um i have gone to
bed angry at my wife before i've never
woken up angry at her though so that's
the point
but even if i ever did
that's okay because anger is not the
worst thing in the world arguments are
not the worst thing
and this ultimately is my problem with
this life coaching duo they probably
know more about marriage than i do i'll
accept that but i am familiar with being
a human being and i know
what i know about being a human being is
that anger and conflict comes in the
bargain so they present never arguing as
an ideal
you know something to strive for but but
is it
let's think about that how could you
actually manage
to go decades without ever so much as
arguing with your spouse
or or with anyone that you spend that
much time with
one way is to be if you're both perfect
like christ himself
um assuming that's not the case here
then we're left with other options not
another is to be emotionless robots or
lobotomy patients
if not that you know if you aren't
perfect and if you have emotions
and you aren't siamese twins joined at
the brain who think and feel exactly the
same all the time then the only other
way to totally avoid arguing is to
suppress your anger when you feel it you
have to always 100 of the time keep the
lid on tamp down any anger that you feel
and funnel everything through the use of
i statements and other therapist
approved conflict resolution strategies
now if you do this always all the time
you may never argue but is that really
ideal
should we be presenting arguments in a
marriage like an objectively bad thing
to be avoided at all costs does the fact
that you've never argued if that's true
make you more of an expert and give you
more credibility or less
now i admit that maybe i'm biased here
because my wife and i are both a couple
of stubborn sons of guns and we both
could be argumentative by nature and
neither of us probably would have
wanted to marry someone who is at all
times meek and mild and avoids conflict
that just sounds boring frankly but my
bias aside it seems to me that an
argument is simply when two people
have diverging ideas about something and
they both are insisting on their own
point of view
that's an argument and it's not it's not
bad there's nothing there's nothing
necessarily bad about that
this is another feminist just like the
idea that uh i mentioned before two men
are in an argument and the worst thing
that ever happened is any kind of
physical altercation
well there's also this idea that the
arguments themselves are always bad
things
um
arguments happen when people are
asserting contradictory viewpoints now
there are bad ways to assert your point
of view if you're screaming and cussing
that's bad
obviously in a marriage between a man
and a woman if it's a if it's this is an
argument between men and women if you're
getting physical that's always bad also
if you constantly feel the need to
assert your view about every little
thing
then all you're going to do is argue and
that's bad but if you never assert your
view if you never plant your foot on the
ground and say no this is how i think we
should go about this and i'm insisting
we do it this way if you never ever do
that
well then your conflict avoidance
becomes dishonesty your spouse won't
know who you really are what you
actually think what you actually feel
because you're always conforming
yourself immediately to whatever the
other person wants or feels
i hardly see that as ideal
now the point isn't to avoid arguing but
rather to argue well i think
i don't mean argue well as in knowing
how to destroy your spouse with facts
and logic though you should be able to
do that and i have done that to my wife
before whether she realizes it or not
but what i mean is is arguing in a
healthy way
which means keeps keeping things in
perspective
not blowing every little conflict out of
proportion
i mean staying on topic okay never
saying anything that starts with oh yeah
remember the time when you
it means letting the other person
actually say their piece and it means
allowing the argument to end
so
once you've said what you need to say
and they've said what they need to say
let it in go to bed like leave the room
whatever arguments can be healthy but
the unhealthy one have the healthy ones
have time limits
every healthy argument can turn
unhealthy if it drags on too long
marital spats are like you know gremlins
don't feed them after midnight
don't keep it going past a certain point
say what you need to say listen to what
the other person is saying and then move
on that's a healthy heart such things do
exist
they're even i would say an important
part of your marriage
and that's why
i'm not going to cancel the key leads
themselves because they seem like nice
people but the idea that they're
proposing is what i'm going to cancel
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated